welcome back to Quantum Computing in practice I'm your host Olivia Lanes last time we walked through an example of a
Quantum Computing approach to an optimization problem known as Max cup using the Cubo formulation we went
pretty far in depth but that was just one example of one approach today we are going to discuss near-term applications
more broadly and develop our intuition for different types of problems we expect to find useful Quantum solutions
for and see some recent examples of some important work done in our community at a utility
scale previously we briefly discussed that not all problems have the need for additional computational power
specifically Quantum Computing in order to be solved efficiently these are the problems that you're already most
familiar with arithmetic scrolling social media maybe playing Tetris Doom or other video games we broadly consider
these easy problems on the other hand there are very hard problems such as finding prime factors of enormous
integers and this is the basis of RSA encryption and what sh's algorithm was actually designed to solve another
example is finding a solution in an unsorted data set this can theoretically be solved by the quantum algorithm known
as Grover's algorithm however most experts agree that these types of algorithms will necessitate the
implementation of error correction and we're just not there yet technologically speaking so as we go forward in this
lesson and in your Quantum educational Journey remember we are looking for this Sweet Spot somewhere here in the middle
it's a hard problem to crack but that's also what makes it so fun one thing we've not yet discussed
much is computational complexity Theory one of the reasons being is that it can be somewhat intimidating and yes
complex computational complexity theory is the field of computer science that aims to classify computational Problems
by how difficult they are are a ton of different complexity classes in classical Computing but the most
fundamental are these P problems these were problems that can be solved in polinomial time at the scale as the
problem increase meaning that they are easy to solve the next more difficult type of problem is NP problems which
stands for non-deterministic polinomial these are problems whose answers can be verified in polinomial time but not
necessarily solved next is NP comp complete and now we're getting into the really challenging problems with no
known polinomial solution this is where famous problems like the traveling salesman problem and even the game
Sudoku live now when Quantum Computing came to be at least in theory people spent a considerable effort trying to
figure out what class of problems these new types of computers would be able to solve efficiently a new class of
problems were invented called bounded error Quantum polinomial problems or bqp for short their strict definition is a
little long but it is the class of decision Problem solvable by a quantum computer in polinomial time with a small
chance of error there's a chance of error because Quantum measurement is inherently random but the error
probability can be arbitrarily small now all of these classes live in a larger class we call pspace and this is where
we think bqp lives relative to all of the other types of problems but it's very hard to definitively prove this
mathematically you'll notice that bqp Quantum problems do not necessarily overlap with NP complete problems
however you might have still seen some Quantum Computing approaches that aim to solve NP complete problems why would
this be one common misconception is that there is no point in exploring solutions
to problems like the traveling salesman and other NP complete problems for a quantum computer or any problem or a
mathematical proof for a Quantum speed up has not been found however this doesn't necessarily have to be the case
finding mathematical proof that a Quantum algorithm is faster than its classical counterpart is rare Shore and
Grover are two of the only handful of examples where this has been done so far but that is okay in fact computer
scientists still haven't even been able to prove that the classes of p and NP are different even though all intuition
tells us that they must be also comparing two algorithms and how they scale often looks at the worst case
scenario for each it is quite possible that in practice the worst case scenario is not what we find in real life so we
do not despair we introduce instead the idea of heuristic Solutions if you're an
experimentalist you already know and love these types of solutions a heuristic is any approach to solving a
problem that is pragmatic but not necessarily optimal and that's great because Solutions don't necessarily have
to be optimal in order to be very useful for instance think about a financial application we haven't yet found an
exponential speed up for most Financial algorithms that Quantum could be used for yet but that doesn't necessarily matter we don't need an optimal solution
in finance at least because a solution that is even just 1% more efficient could equate to billions of dollars
worth of profit so how do we know what use cases and problems could be suitable for Quantum Computing right now and by that
I mean there's significant reason to believe Quantum utility or even Advantage could be found either now or
in the somewhat near future maybe it's easier to first name things that the problem should certainly not have it
can't require a huge number of cubits we don't have processors yet that have thousands to millions of cubits available that's one of the main reasons
Shores algorithm and the like are so far off the circuits also can't be incredibly deep it's really hard for me
to tell you exactly what circuit depth won't work because it depends on so many factors but in general if your
experiment requires a depth that you haven't seen achieved in the literature yet you might be in for a rough time and
lastly any type of algorithm that we know will require error correction cannot be done yet what we should look for however are experiments that make
use of most of the cubits available on any given qpu we have also emphasize the
importance of error mitigation and suppression and lastly there should be an obvious extension to Future
applications that would be important for society and that we could see eventually leading to Quantum
Advantage now let's talk about some examples of use cases which fall into three main categories that we have
identified as most likely to see favorable outcomes in the near to Middle
term the first area is the simulation of nature we've spoken about this previously there
are so many opportunities for quantum computers to improve the research being done on the molecular and atomic level
and the reason for this is because current classical methods are limited by fundamentally inefficient mathematical
descriptions of atomic structures storing and manipulating a Quantum State takes an exponential amount of resources
on a classical computer but can be done efficiently on a quantum computer and that's what makes material simulation
and chemical modeling some of the most promising application areas more specifically this could lead to
developments in carbon dioxide sequestration alternative batteries or the invention of new drugs some
algorithms that are especially relevant in this area are the variational quantum igen solver vqe which is used to
estimate certain properties of a material such as equilibrium or minimum energy states another example is the
time Dynamic simulation TDS that algorithm is used to estimate response functions or spectral properties of
materials and I also wanted to mention a newcomer sample based Quantum diagonalization which we think will we
will hearing a lot more about in the near future the next application area is optimization now optimization is pretty
ubiquitous in Computing as you can imagine so the use cases are quite numerous and varied
however some examples that we hear about a lot are portfolio optimization in finance industrial design and also
distribution and supply chain the most common algorithm you will probably hear related to optimization is the one we
have already covered in some depth the quantum approximate optimization algorithm or
qaoa lastly one area that there has been a lot of excitement for in the past few years is quantum machine learning now I
think it's fair to say that it looks like qml isn't going going to happen as soon as simulation will in all likelihood but nevertheless there are
some impressive algorithms people are working on consistently corresponding to some very important use
cases some of these possible use cases are natural language processing Network traffic analysis and even fraud
detection in financial transactions relevant algorithms in this area are the quantum support Vector
machine Quantum neural networks andant Quantum generative adversarial networks now to clarify those three
groups that we just described are broad application areas it is also worth noting that in the community there is
also benefit to groups working together who are focused on a specific topic IBM spearheaded an initiative not too long
ago called The Working groups to try to help collaborators meet and create productive Synergy in four specific
areas Healthcare and life science materials and HPC high energy physics and
optimization here are our current groups and the entities involved in those efforts if you want to hear more about
what the working groups are doing we have attached four of their white papers in the description below now like I said
I think the best thing to do at this point in the course is to spend some time exploring which sorts of problems people are working on on The Cutting
Edge of this technology and developing our intuition for knowing what types of algorith iths are going to work and how
to apply them and before we begin I just want to make it very clear that the main goal here is not to understand every
detail of the experiments this type of analysis can be very intimidating for even experts if the paper is slightly
out of your area of expertise the goal is simply to help develop an intuition for the types of problems quantum
computers are good for and how to handle them and if you're interested in the finer details and this has sparked some
ideas of your own I definitely encourage you to go and read the full papers themselves the specific use cases and
papers that we are going to be taking an in-depth look at are these first we will explore a paper that discusses
simulation of hadron Dynamics This falls into the high energy physics category next we will look at an optimization
problem specifically bias field counter adiabatic Quantum optimization and lastly we will look at yet another
simulation problem but this time focusing on mRNA a crucial molecule for
drug and therapeutic development if you're familiar or not with these papers that's no problem we are going to walk
through them all three are important papers that tackle problems of substantial size and show how quantum
computers are beginning to be used as another method of scientific inquiry first up is simulating hadron
Dynamics and we're going to delve into a paper by Martin Savage's group at the University of Washington called Quantum
simulations of hadron Dynamics in the schwinger model using 112
cubits if you're not a high energy physicist you might still be familiar with the term hadron such as in the
Large Hadron Collider or the LHC which is the giant particle accelerator 27 kilometers in circumference that made it
possible to finally observe the higs Bon now I had is a subatomic composite particle made up of other small
particles called quarks some examples would be neutrons and protons for a little bit of context the LHC was built
to allow for the study of fundamental physics and what happens to particles when they Collide at super high energies
in this circular tube by doing this scientists hope to learn more about how the early Universe came into existence
and like I previously said it was also used to find the Bon which is an elusive particle responsible for mass of
fundamental particles now in principle the interactions of these particles could be
simulated from start to finish with a sufficiently powerful quantum computer we're not quite there yet but progress
is being made now the Sher model is a simple model used to simulate some of these Dynamics and has emerged as one of
the most popular models of choice the details of the model are not super super important for right now but for those
curious it is a model that describes the behavior of electrons and positrons interacting via photons in 1 + 1 D
Dimensions meaning that there's one spatial Dimension and time the model has a lot of similarities to Quantum
chromodynamics which describes how quarks and hadrons interact now that's extremely hard to simulate so the
schwinger model is often used as a toy model to invest some phenomena that are actually common to
both now the way we are going to proceed with this example and the rest of the examples I have selected here as well is
by asking ourselves a series of questions the first is why did we have reason to believe that simulating this
on a quantum computer would work at all in this case the electrons and positrons in the schwinger model have a screening
effect causing correlations between distant Fons to Decay exponentially with separation and this means that there
aren't as many long range interactions from a cubit on one side of the chip to another on the other side of the chip
which we know is very error prone so this is really good for the hardware that we have available today next is
this topic even of Interest well I hop I have already sort of convinced you that yes high energy physics is of great
interest people were willing to spend billions of dollars to build the LHC and thousands of scientists and and
technicians across the globe have dedicated their lives to this field that's how important it is but the
shringer model is simplistic and isn't designed to cover three spatial Dimensions nevertheless it is an
important model as it still provides currently testable slices and useful simplification of a full
Theory last how was this work done or what approach would they use if they were looking to continue the work in
simulation type experiments vqe is one of the most common approaches and is the first step is almost always the same
prepare the ground state in this case it is a vacuum State and in this experiment they use a new version a vqe called SC
adapt vqe to prepare both the ground state and the hron wave packet on top of the vacuum the next step is to then
allow the hadrons to evolve or propagate in time lastly we need to identify the
observables that we want to detect now if those steps sounded kind of familiar to you minus the Hadron wave
packet part that's because these steps are very similar to what we covered in the qaoa example in the previous episode
hopefully you're starting to see some patterns emerging here the components needed for vqe are very similar to qaoa
we start in a familiar State here the vacuum State and then we let it evolve in time with a series of exponentiated
hamiltonians divided into manageable chunks where n is the number of Divisions the only big difference here
is we create the wave packet of hadron centered within our circuit before we start letting it evolve so how is this
done well the vacuum state is the ground state and we've already sort of covered how to map this now preparing the Hadron
wave packet is a bit different on this vacuum a hadron can be exciting by creating a firon anti- fermon pair on
adjacent sites by preparing a superposition of such hadrons at different locations an arbitrary wave
packet can be prepared the authors centered their wave packet in the middle of the circuit to observe the evolution
without exceeding a boundary but remember the name of the game when working with noisy qpu is to keep the
circuit depth manageable to do this the SC adapt vqe protocol uses symmetry and
hierarchies in length scales to determine low depth Quantum circuits for State preparation the idea is that this
will create an onzo with a smaller number of parameters equating to a shallower depth more details can of
course be found in the paper than we have time to cover here so make sure to check it out now let's take a look at the results this experiment was run on
an IBM Quantum Heron device and implemented a few different types of airor mitigation and supression
including a more recent technique called operator decoherence renormalization as well as dynamical de coupling zero noise
extrapolation and poly twirling now let's try to interpret the data the observable that we're actually going to
be measuring to observe how the wave packet propagates is something called the chyal condensate which is a bit
abstract but it's basically a superf fluid phase of the hadrons now we can see the wave packet centered here on the
sites that have been designated to run this experiment where the color corresponds to the chyro condensate the
left side shows the airfree results from the simulator while the right side shows the results from the IBM quantum
computer Torino ideally these would be mirror images of one another due to symmetry so you can see that there are
some imperfections now this vertical y AIS corresponds to the chunks of time I
measured earlier so why don't we take some horizontal cuts through the first and last time steps of the data to see
what happens to the wave packet at Time tals 1 here in Orange corresponding to
this cut you can see that the caral condensate is narrow and localized it it also corresponds really well to the
simulation that was done for comparison at tal 14 however though it is much more spread out and is less
localized maybe the comparison to the simulator isn't quite as perfect now but you can still obviously see very good agreement between Theory and the data
which is encouraging in conclusion this is a very cool example of the type of simulation work you might not initially think about
applying quantum computers to however in fact you can and it works it's not perfect but you don't have to be a
particle physics expert to see that the quantum computer accuracy predicts the outward propagation of the wave packet
which is exactly what we would expect to find hopefully future work in this area will continue and high energy physicists
will continue to find ways to incorporate Quantum Computing into their work streams the aim is to solve theoretical problems more precisely and
those which can't be done classically and use experiments to accept or reject theories in hopes of discovering new
physics building improved detectors and leading to a better understanding of nature at its most fundamental
level our next example focuses on optimization and will be a deep dive into a paper called biased field
digitized counter adiabatic Quantum optimization which was done by members of the kipu quantum team in the
University of the bass country in Spain we'll begin like we did before
with a series of definitions the first is counter adiabatic which is a type of evolution that suppresses non-adiabatic
effects experienced by a system regardless of how fast those processes occur recall the adiabatic theorem from
the last episode you usually need to let a system evolve very slowly if you wish for it to remain in the ground state
this is a big problem because the slower we have to let things evolve the more time we have for errors to
occur counter adiabatic driving often abbreviated as CD aims to combat this by
adding terms that counteract these unwanted excitations the main idea here is to speed up the whole experiment and
reduce edce Quantum circuit depth by suppressing excitations that could lead to spous
Transitions now let's talk about what a bias field is other iterative algorithms like vqe take classical parameters into
these states and use classical optimizers to search the many dimensional parameter space for that set
that yields a minimum expectation value for a fixed hamiltonian in this case they instead vary the hamiltonian each
time moving adiabatically from a known case to the case of interest but since there are no classical parameters being
passed and no variational wave function how do you update your state from one pass at the hamiltonian to the next well
they add a bias feel to the hamiltonian whatever the lowest energy state from the previous run they add a term in the
hamiltonian to the bias the state in favor of that so why is this experiment of
Interest well first of all this is a new approach that could be applied more generally to other optimization problems
but in this case they applied it to an ising spin glass problem as we discussed previously many combinatorial
optimization problems can be reformulated as solving for low energy states of ising hamiltonians the ising
model is a series of microscopic spins distributed on an array the model can be used to describe a spin glass in which
the magnetization is disordered basically the little magnetic moments are oriented randomly in the array and
why did we think this would work well we already sort of covered how we are combating two typical issues found in
variational algorithms when we covered the definitions of the paper but to summarize the algorithm they are
proposing speeds up the evolution to reduce the circuit depth while also suppressing non-adiabatic transitions
furthermore it does not rely on any classical optimization routine which can be an issue leading to Barren
plateaus and getting stuck at local Minima lastly the authors also make sure to align the interactions in the problem
hamiltonian with the hardware connectivity in the real qpu which is always very important lastly how does this work so
like I said there are no classical optimizers being used here like there often is in iterative Quantum algorithms
instead by feeding the solution from each iteration into to the input for the next one the bias field digitized
Quantum optimization algorithm incrementally refines the ground state bringing it closer and closer to the
final evolved State and combined with counter adiabatic protocols we can do this even with short depth Quantum
circuits that should run smoothly on noisy Hardware so when the experiment was performed the authors chose to run the
algorithm on the 127 Cubit IBM quantum computer Brisbane here the author showed
the eth ization of the optimization algorithm for a nearest neighbor randomly generated spin glass instance
over 100 cubits they compare ideal simulation results from dcq and bf dcq
as well as the experimental result and they also show a result from a classical solver called goobi as a reference now
with just 10 iterations BF dcq provides a drastic enhancement compared to
dcq although the experimental result is a bit different than the ideal result due to noise the performance is still
better than the ideal dcq this shows that there's still a lot of excellent progress being made with
regards to Quantum optimization and good results are being reported on over 100 cubits for one of the first
times last but not least is a very interesting paper exploring mRNA structure prediction from our friends at
madna Pharmaceuticals and it's called mRNA secondary structure prediction using utility scale quantum
computers to begin if you like me still haven't taken a biology course in a few years you can refresh yourself on what
mRNA is messenger RNA is a type of RNA involved in protein synthesis it
basically reads instructions given by DNA the secondary structure of mRNA is more or less how the chain is folded and
the RNA secondary structure prediction proc problem is the problem of finding the most stable folding of the sequence
of bases of nucleotides that make up DNA and RNA that would be c g u and a this
image here shows some of the common folding structures found in mRNA each color highlighting here shows a
different secondary structure but the exact characteristics for what makes one of these structures more favorable over
another isn't well understood all we can do is figure out which which one has the lowest free energy compared to the
unfolded state and that's where quantum computers step in so why are mRNA secondary structures
important well accurate prediction of them is actually crucial and not only understanding DNA and our genes but also
for Designing RNA based Therapeutics like the covid-19 vaccine there is reason to believe that the approach in
this paper would work because this has long been known to be a formidable optimiz ation problem for classical
computers due to the vast number of possible configurations and for some configurations it's actually known to be
an NP complete problem however on a quantum computer we can formulate the secondary structure prediction as a
binary optimization problem something we know how to handle furthermore there has been evidence in the literature already
of accurate RNA prediction on small scale Quantum devices and Quantum simulators so the obvious question is
would this work on larger Hardware the experiment is done by using something called the conditional value
at risk variational Quantum igen solver which is a modification to the traditional vqe algorithm and is
expected to achieve better convergence this plot shows the distribution of measurement
probabilities of the sample bit strings with the corresponding energies for 42
nucleotide 80 Cubit instance here the bit strings symbolize pairings of the
nucleotides it illustrates that the lowest energy bit string has an energy value ofus 140 which matches the lowest
energy bit strength found by the comparative classical solver so that's great and this is the optimal folded
structure of that nucleotide chain based on the lowest energy bit string the hardware has
found and with that we have reached the conclusion of this episode now my aim here was not to overwhelm you with
details from different research papers like I said I simply wanted to give you an all enough context understand what
Cutting Edge work in the field looks like right now the hope is that this will get some gears turning in
everybody's head and that by seeing how others are approaching problems you will be able to make connections and have the
confidence to attempt new Quantum experiments that you might not have before and hey maybe some of those won't
pan out and that's fine that's why this is research going forward remember that the types of problems that we are
interested in can be grouped by either methodology or by subject and we have laid out the ones that we believe to be
the most promising in the short term remember Quantum Computing isn't good for everything and really this is just a
testament to how good we've gotten at classical Computing just because you think you could apply Quantum Computing
to a problem doesn't mean it's going to yield interesting results unfortunately you have to consider the scaling circuit
depth is a double-edged sword we need it to be considerably large to do interesting work that classical
computers can't but right now because of the hardware noise we can't push it to huge sizes because the Fidelity will
diminish it's all about finding that sweet spot and knowing that it is a moving Target so take some time in
between now and the next episode to really think about some problems that you have come across and how you might want to approach them with what we have
learned up and to this point be creative and don't limit yourself and if you have any ideas even if you think they're a
little bit crazy let me know in the comments below thanks for watching and I'll see you next time